In the sci-fi comedy Galaxy Quest, there’s
a scene where a human pretending to be an
alien is horrified by the food his species
is supposed to like.
While the scene is played for laughs, it’s
interesting to think about the strange little
details of alien daily life, like what they
have for dinner, that most stories don’t
include.
Enter The Birg Project, a worldbuilding series
that brings to life an expansive alien ecosystem,
but also delves into the most minute cultural
details of its central intelligent species.
Created by the brilliant artist Ripley, The
Birg Project doesn’t just explore the biology
of its titular aliens, but also imagines how
they put on clothes, how they play the horn,
even how they sneeze.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
explore the incredible world of the Birgs.
And as usual, you can follow the artist on
social media and see more of her project using
the links in the description.
Now, let’s explore this alien planet on
both a macro and micro scale…
We’ll start with the Birgs themselves.
Also called ‘Birdbugs,’ these extraterrestrials
superficially resemble a cross between Earth
birds and Earth bugs — and have developed
a level of intelligence similar to our own.
The planet they evolved on is a habitable
world with extreme seasonal variations, meaning
the Birgs must hibernate for much of the year.
Internally, Birg bones don’t all connect
in the way ours do, as the ancestor of most
land animals on their planet had an exoskeleton
like Earth insects.
In the eons since, Birgs and their kin have
convergently developed vertebrae to support
their necks, but their ribs are still free-floating.
Birg mouths are made of two nimble pinchers
that can move independently, as this biomechanical
visualization illustrates.
This means that Birg jaws function more like
the mouthparts of Earth spiders than of vertebrates.
Another visualization of Birg biomechanics
shows us how the creatures breathe: they take
in oxygen through apertures near their eyes,
which in turn lead to lungs located in their
neck, and they then exhale from exhaust apertures
on their sides.
And as mentioned before, here’s how a Birg
sneezes…
Like humans, Birgs have a range of facial
expressions they use to communicate emotion.
To our eyes, these expressions might be hard
to read, but to Birgs, these emotive displays
are just as intricate as our own — with
mandibles, eyes, and antennae position coming
into play.
You may have already noticed that most Birgs
possess fine hairs over much of their bodies,
which helps them keep warm during the long
winter months of their home world.
Much of the Birg’s rounded shape actually
comes from this fluff, and without it they
appear like withered, skeletal lifeforms.
Because of their fur, clothing isn’t the
same kind of cultural requirement it is in
most human societies.
Yet many Birgs still wear garments to further
shield themselves from the elements, show
off their wealth, or denote their nationality.
For Birg societies are just as complex as
our own...
And like humans, Birg civilization has been
shaped in no small part by the numerous other
species on their planet.
Trunkhorses are among the most invaluable
species to Birg society, serving as both steeds
and guardians of Birg children.
This mare keeps a watchful eye on her foals
as she grazes — and while one of her foals
looks different than the others, she guards
it just as fiercely.
Another steadfast companion of the Birgs are
the Jaubja, dog-like creatures that have been
at the Birg’s side since the dawn of their
civilization.
Like Earth dogs, many breeds of Jaubja exist
— with most acting as pest control and highly
territorial guardians of farmland.
Like cats, Jaubja are largely self-domesticated
— meaning they chose to integrate with Birg
society as a survival strategy.
And Birgs keep other types of pets as well.
Here, a child proudly displays their prized
Scalebugs.
These colorful creatures spend their larval
stage in the bark of certain trees, where
they are collected by local kids and raised
to their adult stage.
These vibrant pets are considered fashionable,
and function almost like living jewelry.
Birgs also cultivate insects called ‘pottery
bees’ in large farms.
The bees themselves are rarely consumed, but
a fungus that the bees grow for food is considered
a regional delicacy.
Populations are carefully maintained by local
keepers, protecting the large mud nests with
fences and moats.
It is custom for pottery bee-keepers to leave
a small token as “payment” for the harvested
product.
On farms, the larger ‘Bumblebird’ classification
of insects plays key roles as pollinators.
Many plants have co-evolved pits full of sugary
reservoirs to lure in Bumblebirds, who then
spread their pollen to other plants — a
convergent relationship to that of flowers
and Earth bumblebees.
Most insects on the Birg planet are covered
in scales, which have developed into protective
exoskeletons in some clades.
Many flying clades of insects lay their larvae
within specific crops, and sometimes play
a vital role in the life-cycle of the plants.
These strange parasites are a hugely important
resource to the Birgs both as pollinators
and as food—and are also consumed for their
mind-altering properties.
For Birgs who live on the coasts, most of
their food comes not from the land, but from
the sea.
Coastal Birgs partake in a wide variety of
seafood fresh from the planet’s bountiful
oceans.
Fish within the waters of the Birg homeworld
take on a variety of curious and startling
forms, with most possessing the multi-part
mouths common throughout most lineages on
the planet.
Some of the largest creatures in the ocean
are filter-feeders with specialized mouths
that funnel zooplankton into baleen like structures
on their jowls.
While these creatures might not look it, they
share a common ancestor with the dog-like
Jaubja that the Birgs keep as pets.
Elsewhere on the coast, there’s also a species
of crab-like lifeforms — which is good,
because all speculative settings should have
some form of crab.
Further inland, the Flagdeer family sports
some of the tallest creatures found on Birgworld.
These towering lifeforms are related to the
Trunkhorses, although their trunks have become
lengthy, flagpole-like appendages used to
reach leaves on the tops of trees — much
like the long necks of Earth giraffes.
On the opposite end of the spectrum, snuffling
around the bottoms of trees are pig-like,
armored herbivores that feed on bark and roots.
Their sharp mandibles can inflict serious
harm on would-be predators, so most creatures
keep their distance.
The tree-like plants of the Birg planet are
quite different from trees here on Earth.
Sun-spires are towering plants with leaves
that grow in tightly clustered chambers like
giant compound eyes.
These lenses act like a magnifying glass,
helping to optimize photosynthesis, and the
Birgs once used them to make decorative windows,
sun catchers, and even primitive spectacles
and telescopes.
Today, Sun-spire lenses are more commonly
farmed to make distinctive jewelry.
A ubiquitous group of trees are the Feathervanes,
plants that are named for their feather-like
assemblage of leaves.
Though equivalent to Earth trees in certain
ways, Feathervanes diverge in their production
of ‘walking seeds’ — a mobile stage
of their reproductive cycle that can amble
along in search of ideal land in which to
begin the more familiar ‘plant’ stage
of their lifecycle.
Different walking seeds have different specializations,
and most briefly fill an insect-like niche
within their ecosystem.
In silica rich soils, landscapes of coiling
vines dominate the scenery.
These mounds take thousands of years to reach
their current size, with successive layers
of vines growing on top of the old ones in
a reef-like fashion.
And like marine reefs, they support a diverse
assemblage of life, including local Birgs
that hunt for small game.
Yet Birgs aren’t always the ones doing the
hunting.
Many Birgs are still very much in the middle
of a larger food web, and there are various
apex predator species that can turn a Birg
into their lunch — especially during the
planet’s long winters when Birgs need to
hibernate.
And there is no deadlier predator of the hibernation
period than the Omb.
The source of the Birg’s darkest legends,
these beasts have sensitive mechanoreceptors
in their legs that allow them to locate burrows
hidden underground.
The Omb’s habit of exhuming hibernating
animals has inspired countless horror stories
of Birgs’ homes being torn into in the dead
of the night…
For even at mid-latitudes, Birgworld winters
are easily as cold, dark, and vicious as those
seen in the far polar regions of Earth.
Nothing roams these snows save the lumbering
beasts that prey on the bones of the dead
as readily as they wrest sleeping creatures
from their hidden burrows.
Aesthetically and thematically, the Birg project
takes inspiration from the 1984 Hayao Miyazakifilm
Nausicaä of the Valley of the Wind.
Based on a manga of the same name, the film
tells the story of a post-apocalyptic Earth
with a toxic ecosystem, where the last humans
struggle to coexist with giant insects.
The visual parallels between the surreal,
insect-dominated ecosystems of Nausicaä and
the Birg project are evocative.
During the early stages of production, director
Miyazaki created several water color paintings
to help decide the look of his futuristic
biosphere, and these early storyboards in
particular echo through the style of the Birg’s
planet.
In different ways, both stories explore themes
of conflict between society and nature.
Again and again in Nausicaä, humans are reminded
that the Earth is something beyond their control,
and trying to resist this only ends in self-destruction.
Likewise, for all their intelligence, the
Birgs don’t have dominion over their unforgiving
planet.
They are just a single thread in a larger
ecological tapestry, with all aspects of their
culture shaped by their environment…
Yet different Birg civilizations have different
relationships with nature, as Birg cultures
are as rich and varied as our own.
One of the most influential groups are the
Twowi — Birgs who control a vast empire
of interconnected cities.
Culture across the Twowi kingdom is endlessly
complex, with an emphasis on folklore and
ceremonial formalities.
When a Twowi dies, family members carry the
body to a special room, where it naturally
mummifies, and they keep in there for a year-long
grieving period.
The body is then cremated and spread to the
wind, with any remaining ashes mixed into
the clay of a little sculpture made to resemble
the departed loved-one.
Most Twowi buildings are wattle and daub,
made from the grey-bluish wood of feathervane
trees and bundles of fibrous grass stuffed
into walls for insulation.
For food, one of the key staple crops in the
Twowi empire are a tuber-like “fungus”
that act as roots to the feathervane trees.
With their agriculture and city building,
the Twowi are quite different from most nomadic
Birg cultures.
Yet the Twowi still engage in many traditional
Birg practices, like the grooming of each
other’s fuzz to remove dirt and unwanted
parasites.
This social grooming behavior is not unlike
that of certain Earth primates, and is a way
for the Birgs to deepen their bonds.
Some of the most esteemed community members
are Moonwatchers, shamans who forgo winter
hibernation in order to guard their sleeping
communities from the physical and spiritual
horrors of the long cold night.
For even in the Twowi empire, Birgs are never
fully separate from nature.
Of course, Twowi aren’t the only Birgs with
distinct cultures.
Some Birg societies practice scarification,
using scaring to creature cosmetic patterns
in their fuzz growth.
And most Birg societies have their own form
of music, like these ceremonial horns designed
to resemble the mouths of Trunkhorses.
Due to Birgs’ unique biology, the ‘mouthpieces’
cover their exhaust spiracles.
Unique instruments present in the Twowi empire
are standing devices functionally similar
to the accordion, with bellows pumped by the
medial arms while the anterior hands press
the keys.
Nearly all Birg societies engage in, uh, chemical
recreation — which can range from Grubfruits,
which have perception altering effects on
Birgs — to the shaved bark of certain plants,
which relaxes their body and mind.
In Birg culture, these stimulants play an
important role in social bonding, and are
expected at most gatherings.
One of the weirder forms of recreation the
Birgs have involve slumber-bugs, scorpion-like
creatures that produce venom which medics
have historically used as painkillers.
However, some Birgs use them… less responsibly,
which over centuries has led to various breeds
with creative names and variations in potency.
While not outlawed, slumber-bug use is widely
seen as a bad idea.
Like many ancient and modern human cultures,
Birgs have created a wide array of mobility
aids.
Canes and crutches come in a few different
forms, with their shape depending on which
Birg limb needs the most support.
In the windy equatorial region, strange statues
suggest Birg civilization has a long history.
The Singing Giants, mysterious statues that
make an eerie whistling noise when the wind
blows through the holes in their heads, lie
scattered on the plains.
Their original purpose is unknown, but the
local nomads believe their humming are the
voices of passing ghosts.
Much of Birg religion is tied to seasonal
changes and environmental forces.
Some communities participate in ritualistic
brush burning: removing dead grasses so new
ones can spring up.
At seasonal festivals, Birgs who wish to show
off don flashy costumes and circle around
each other in a mock battle.
Referees judge participants in these dancing
rituals on their synchronicity and how close
they stay to their partner without touching
them.
And like all known human cultures, Birg societies
have legends of monsters, one of which this
folk costume is meant to depict.
As on Earth, most of these mythical beings
do not actually exist…
…But perhaps some do.
A widespread legend amoung Birgs tells of
an eerie creature, something like a great
worm with many legs that stalks the thickets
at night.
Some say they come from the underworld, or
perhaps they are mischievous spirits of the
wild.
But in truth, these secretive, nocturnal lifeforms
are called Millipeebs — a highly intelligent
species that quietly coexist with the Birgs
in the remote corners of the planet.
Their exact intelligence is difficult to measure.
Perhaps they are as smart as dolphins — or
perhaps they’re just as intelligent as the
Birgs themselves.
In any case, these wise, elusive beings have
stayed hidden from the Birgs for untold generations
by retreating into huge dirt mounds during
the day.
Perhaps one day, as empires like the Twowi
continue to expand, a fateful meeting will
finally occur...
Some of the most interesting pieces from the
Birg project depict the experiences of the
Twowi and other groups on the edge of the
frontier.
They show an almost mythic landscape of discovery
and danger.
Aesthetically, these works take inspiration
from a very unexpected source for a work of
speculative biology: the cinematic language
of westerns.
One of the largest genres of film for over
half a century, classical westerns told stories
of exaggerated heroism and a mythical golden
age of freedom.
In the modern era, however, so called neo-westerns
have sought to re-evaluate the folk stories
of the old west, examining the era under a
more self-aware and critical lens.
While thematically the Birg project strongly
echoes the latter, aesthetically many pieces
pay clever homage to old-school pulp westerns
— taking the iconography of gunslingers,
horses, and outlaws and translating them into
a new dialect of alien imagery.
For example, one image translates the classic
trope of a cattle herder into something…
decidedly unique.
Here, we see a shepherd on a Trunkhorse watching
over their livestock.
These animals themselves aren’t valuable,
but instead serve as hosts to a sort of tick
that is sold as a delicacy in Twowi cities.
On a dusty street corner in a city, an old
herder idles in the afternoon sun.
Far from a heroic folk-tale, life in these
settlements is often tough and short.
In the Twowi borderlands, a proud captain
bears the flag of her modest gang.
Rear end adornments are ubiquitous in Twowi
society, but flags are more formal, used to
identify important members in war parties
and to distinguish friend from foe.
Twowi who venture beyond city limits must
come prepared.
Headgear for shielding the eyes and saddles
adorned with packets for carrying personal
items are key.
It is also common to wear underclothes to
stay protected from the wind and dust.
This particular Birg doing the modeling is
named ‘Swooce’ — and she is something
of a protagonist in this strange, neo-western
mythos.
In one of the most expressive pieces, Swooce
races through the canyonlands, having drawn
the ire of a large aerial predator.
While she still has her firearm, it’s not
doing her much good.
Like most neo-western protagonists, Swooce
experiences more misfortune on the frontier
than dazzling heroics.
More broadly, this section of the Birg project
echoes the neo-western motifs of ordinary
people trying to live ordinary lives yet struggling
to survive…
It seems fitting that a project with an emphasis
on minute details would take inspiration from
a genre built on stories of ordinary lives.
Yet the Birg project is too unique to be pinned
down to any single genre.
The artist states that they feel the project
has expanded beyond its western roots, and
has become now a broader exploration of how
people interact with and are shaped culturally
by their environments — even if, in this
case, the ‘people’ are six-limbed aliens.
If you find this project as fascinating as
I do, you can support the artist on social
media and see more of the Birgs using the
links in the description.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.